明けまして
おめでとうございます
新年早々
突然ですか
私肇社長館
重大な
お知らせがございます
私は初め冊を
2019年
1月15日をもちまして
結婚
いたしません
摂津設定がぜひぜひ地帯地帯期待できましたいけどて金銀切って品て銀
雰囲気期待しちゃこあさあアーサー
失礼致しました今年の
縛りプレイの話です皆さん明けましておめでとうございますというわけでやってまいり
ましたね2019年言いつけが始まってしまったんだろう俺の縛りプレイ俺は1年に
1度必ず何か手針を入れて生活しておかしい挽きすぎたお箸を禁止し始めたのが
2016年2016年にお菓子キンシなんかそのノリでなんかもっとやって
みようと思って記述したのはラーメンとする2018年去年
2018年俺はハードルを上げに開け
肉を1年間禁止したちなみに今なんですけど
ちなみに今1月1日の65分なんですけどもまだお肉は食べておりません
おっじゃなくて食べれないんですよお肉であるのはまた別の動画でしてねーずも今年の
縛りプレイを始めちゃおうかなと思いまして
まあいろいろ考えたらお菓子中止しラーメン禁止しそしてお姉ちゃん大きい
獅子いろいろ考えましたただ俺はこの3つの禁止をしてきてある10代のことに気づい
てしまったそう
食べ物を禁止するのは
part 2良くないそう
お肉を禁止してもっまあいやを入金し関係はちょっと別の動画で話しますよね子供
引き続きあの今まで通り頑張っていくのでよろしくお願い致しますでここでなんです
けどもまぁ縛りプレイの話です皆さん君あってるでしょ
これ以上先の縛りプレイにどんなものがあるのか皆さん仲いいんだよ
そこで私考えに考え決めば
した
コート生地年間の処理部の内容発表いたします
[音楽]
私肇社長は
今年自然
ずつしか来ませ
[拍手]
[音楽]
小僧政治ね私シュートしか
きません食べ物の禁止はねちょっとも飽きた食べ物を禁止してもいいことでただただ何
か変なこのモヤモヤが食べるんで
もっとメーカーなんて思っていろいろ調べたり考えたり威厳を聞いたりしたんですけど
もたとえ急いだ結果
スーツ1年きてみるといいんじゃねって思ったわけですスーツ1年切る理由その1長身
に帰れる皆様ユーチューバーされ者謝罪どうかと
というものをよく上げますもちろん僕も挙げたことあります取材どうぞを撮る時大抵の
ユーチューバーさんはスーツを着ているんですあれなぜかと言いますと静止に誠意
心を表す入れからスーツを着ているんです真心を込めて動画を撮っているとれ果たして
謝罪動画だけでいいのかいなー謝罪動画だけスーツである必要はありません
ご覧ください4
外人の皆様常にスーツを着ています
会社によってですけどスーツでもやはり構成し生の孫頃を表するッ
大切な正装でございますた際動画だけではなく常に日頃の動画から精神性動画を取ると
気持ちを忘れない初戦の国を忘れないためにも真心込めてどうだ作りとしても忘れない
大切な登録者02 dream 気持ちついてんだ気持ちを忘れずに動画を撮るために
は心から変わらなければいけないここ
逃亡者まずは服装からという理由で1年スーツを着てみますよろしくお願い致します
理由増に
スーツを着ているユーチューバーが少ない多分いますよ全然探したらいると思うんです
けどもね僕のしてる同じようなことするユーチューバーさんの中でスーツを着て動画を
撮ってる人がいなかったんであれこれチャンスじゃねと思ってあのスーツを着てみます
へ目立ってなんぼの世界なんでちょっとこうなんか
ね目指したいんですよ矢部皮膚が2つしかない
まあいいでしょ view なんてどうでもいいんです1ね
年間これをすることに意味があるて年縛り内容ちょっとかルートまとめておきました
動画を撮る時はシーツを着て普通に会社行くような感じなんで徒僕なんかは堀田いて
動画撮ってるんでたく星宿もスーツになります
ずーっとこの二ですよね社会人の人は猫の服を演じきって頑張ってるわけですから
大丈夫ですここまできますってかその気をつけろ
大事なんですやってみましょう今年一年前とやっぱり実験系とかねこうイメージのある
服装の時あると思うんですよ撮影に応じた服装には変えることができるんですが私服的
な服のときは必ずスーツを今年1年着氷させていただきます
挑戦でもあの去年撮っとどうか今年まだ出てないのがあったりするんでチェックの動画
がちょっと1月中はでちゃ
あったりするかもしれないけど許してくださいと言うかで今年一年身も心も
リフレッシュし税申請い動画を真剣に作るために
含まれてるよじゃあ
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ